she
my name is lina khalifa
i'm the owner and founder of shifter the
first self-defense studio for women in
the middle east
i teach a mix between
taekwondo boxing
and pure self-defense techniques
we also empower women through seminars
and workshops like domestic violence
sexual harassment assaults and also
women empowerment
i started in 2004 because one of my
friends got abused
by her father and brothers i was really
upset about her situation because i have
a background in martial arts i decided
to start giving lessons for women in
self-defense
domestic violence is the high percent in
jordan in in violence for women
we have street harassment you don't see
lots of girls walking the street because
of that
shifter is safe place for women to come
and talk about their issues because
all the other girls have been mostly the
same experience
the physical training and mental
training both are really important so we
start with talking to the girls about
their stories
then we move to the training
we have trained and empowered more than
12 000 women
before i joined i was facing like a lot
of verbal harassment i felt so weak
because i couldn't do anything about it
since i joined verbal harassment is less
now because i'm more confident now so
when walking in street that shows like
that reflects to other people
most girls here after the training they
feel that
they can't stand up for themselves
it's about providing them with
self-defense skills to defend their
rights and to have a voice in society
you